foreign
Thanksgiving dinner is this where's the
turkey Chuck don't you know anything
about Thanksgiving dinners where's the
mashed potatoes where's the cranberry
sauce where's the pumpkin pie
hello and welcome to a new episode of RT
Essentials I'm Naz Perez
cue Sparkle in the teeth one of the
great things about movies is that
there's one or in most cases many for
just about every holiday known to man
yeah even Arbor Day Has movies and
thankfully our wheel of random holidays
that we keep in a room next to the
Tomato Meter landed on Thanksgiving just
meaning there's no room at the Tomato
Meter but we should do that that would
be really cool now what makes a movie a
Thanksgiving movie can range from a few
pivotal scenes to its Central themes or
its overall setting and time of year
with more to be considered so catch a
plane or a train because this miracle of
an episode is filled with funny people
who will Blindside you with some emails
and the scent of a Thanksgiving movie I
think I smell gravy okay you get it now
time to check out our list of the best
Thanksgiving movies
Planes Trains and Automobiles well I'll
see you tomorrow then gobble gobbles
welcome to Marathon may I help you
you can start by wiping that don't smile
off your rosy cheeks and getting this
trip started is 1987's Planes Trains and
Automobiles now this movie which opened
on the Wednesday before Thanksgiving was
written produced and directed by John
Hughes who had become mostly known for
directing Teen Angst films to that point
this one Stars Steve Martin as a bit of
a control freak advertising man named
Neil who is trying to get from New York
back home to Chicago for Thanksgiving
with his family
after a freak snowstorm puts a wrench in
his plans he combines efforts with a
shower curtain ring salesman named Dell
played by John Candy and together they
face a series of Transportation related
challenges I can relate now along with
its General connections to turkey day as
a final destination in the plot this
film goes above and beyond that with its
ultimately heartfelt message because
when Neil discovers Adele's wife had
passed eight years earlier and he had
nowhere to go Neil brings him home for
Thanksgiving with his family I mean I'm
crying just thinking about it also I
really miss John Candy you know nothing
grinds my gears worse than some chowder
head who doesn't know when to keep a big
trap shut
you catch me running off of the mouth
just give me a poking the chops
oh oh
that feels good oh God I'm telling you
my dogs are barking today
this Planes Trains and Automobiles also
perfectly captures that other very big
part of Thanksgiving travel or more
specifically travel headaches now for
this one many of the highway scenes were
filmed on a stretch of U.S Highway 219
that runs between Buffalo and
Springville New York which was unopened
at the time lucky for them and it was
two travel scenes in particular that
convinced Steve Martin to join the
production the seat adjustment scene in
the car and the f word tirade at the Car
Rental Desk you gotta love it now
deadline reported back in 2020 that a
remake of this film had been in
development with Will Smith and Kevin
Hart starring wouldn't that be good but
I'm not really sure there's a need to
mess with the classic or as a critics
consensus puts it a quote hilarious
heartfelt holiday classic Adams Family
Values this year we depict perhaps the
most important day in our shared past
the first Thanksgiving a day for mage
the Native American word for corn a
terrific turkey dinner
and Brotherhood so like me and dark meat
take it away adding some different kinds
of flavors to this Thanksgiving feast of
films is 1993's Adams Family Values now
this film was written by Paul Rudnick of
Sister Act Fame and directed by Barry
sonenfeld who also directed The Addams
Family in 1991. now this is a sequel to
that film and both are based on cartoons
first published in 1938. the main
connection this movie has for
Thanksgiving is that after the kids
Wednesday and Pugsley are sent to Camp
to improve their behavior they are cast
in a Thanksgiving play but after
refusing to participate they are forced
to watch hours of wholesome family
entertainment in order to change their
ways I mean that would literally be my
dream and when Christina Ritchie's
Wednesday does finally agree to take the
stage as Pocahontas in the Thanksgiving
Play She ultimately sages a coup during
the performance now another very
thanksgiving-esque aspect to Adam's
Family Values is the different levels of
family drama that take place I mean
really no Thanksgiving is complete
without it right is that just my family
the gods of My Tribe have spoken they
have said do not trust the pilgrims
especially
Sarah Miller
Gary she's changing the words and for
all these reasons I've decided to scalp
you
and burn your village to the ground
now in this case Raul Julius Gomez and
Angelica Houston's Morticia have
welcomed a new baby boy leaving the
aforementioned older kids reeling and
Uncle Fester played by Christopher Lloyd
has a gold-dinging new girlfriend played
by Joan Cusack who the rest of the
family is just really not feeling I mean
we've all been there now Adams Family
Values opened the weekend before
Thanksgiving and went on to gross 111
million dollars against a budget of 47
million and it marked the final role
Julia LED film to be released during his
lifetime before his death in 1994. funny
people good to be young kind of sucks
being old so just enjoy this enjoy Time
Time Slips Away I promise you
I had a dinner like this 20 years ago
with guys that
we just like lost touch with each other
I never talked to them anymore some of
them are dead
so uh
yeah you know
things slip away taking a seat at the
table next on this list is 2009's funny
people now this film is written and
directed by Judd Apatow in his first
more serious turn after films like 40
year old virgin and knocked up Adam
Sandler stars in this one and is a comic
named George Simmons who finds out that
he has a fatal disease so he ends up
taking a struggling young performer
named IRA played by Seth Rogen under his
wing at one point during the movie Ira
invites George to Thanksgiving AKA
friendsgiving and George Goes now it's
there that he delivers what many
consider to be one of the most touching
friends giving speeches in film history
he talks about getting older and being
alone and good friends and yada yada now
I'm gonna start crying again it's really
good uh if you love somebody don't let
him slip away
I swear to you
this will be your most memorable
Thanksgiving the one that you'll want
the rest of your life the one that you
say man it was never as good as that
night so let this night be great enjoy
the taste of Leo's ball
now while the Thanksgiving scene stop
there the main friendship between George
and Ira and its underlying
for them is what helps carry the movie
through there's also some serious family
themes going on in funny people in the
metaphorical sense so for instance Judd
Apatow was actually once roommates with
Adam Sandler and he cast him as the lead
plus all kinds of comedians like Sarah
Silverman Norm Macdonald Ray Romano and
George Wallace appears themselves in the
film with Avatar sharing the love around
the comedy community and if you like
your family connections more literal how
about this Apatow's wife Leslie Mann and
their daughters mod and Iris Apatow all
have roles in the film as well and of
course due to their age at the time the
daughters were not allowed to watch the
actual movie hopefully they've seen it
by now You've got mail if I really knew
you I know what I would find instead of
a brain a cash register instead of a
heart a bottom line
what I just had a breakthrough what is
it I have you to thank for it for the
first time in my life when confronted
with a horrible insensitive person I
knew exactly what I wanted to say and I
said it this has got to be one of my
favorite Thanksgiving movies of all time
filling up the inbox of this list next
is 1998's You've Got Mail Nora Ephron
directed this one and co-wrote it with
her younger sister Delia Ephron after
previously collaborating on 1994's mixed
nuts and 96's Michael now this film was
inspired by a 1937 Hungarian play that
was previously adapted as the 1940 movie
the shop around the corner in this late
90s Jam Meg Ryan stars as a struggling
Boutique bookstore owner who unknowingly
strikes up an online friendship with the
owner of the chain bookstore that is
driving her out of business played by Mr
Tom Hanks now of course Ryan and Hanks
previously have appeared together in
films like Joe Versus volcano and
Sleepless in Seattle the latter of which
was also directed by Nora Ephron and
it's that familiar and homely feeling
that we get from the cast and the
director that helps make this one of the
best Thanksgiving movies
plus many memorable moments from this
film happened during the Thanksgiving
season with the beautifulness that is
fall in New York as its backdrop is
there anything hello
hello hi do you need some money no I do
not need any money thank you very much
getting another line hi
Rose
that is a great name Rose this is
Kathleen I'm Joe and I'm Henry Henry how
are you happy holidays this is a credit
card machine
Happy Thanksgiving
and one of the big scenes happens on the
big day of thanks when Tom and Meg's
character meet in a grocery stores cash
only line and she is straight out of
cash ugh the dreaded holiday grocery
shopping yet another one of the
holiday's true Essences captured in the
film and while the fresh You've Got Mail
pulled in a nice worldwide gross of
nearly 251 million it's real success
lies in its sentimentality the kind that
the holidays call for Holiday like
Thanksgiving because all right you get
it
Grumpy Old Men medication yes without it
he could be anywhere wandering around
talking to the trees believe me this man
is a menace she always drinking starting
fights isn't that right but have you
seen him no I think
perhaps
um no no no
this list next is 1993's Grumpy Old Men
now this one was directed by Donald
Petrie of Mystic Pizza fan at the time
and stars Jack Lemmon and Walter Matthau
as two neighbors John and Max who have
been feuding since childhood they're a
rivalry intensifies when a woman moves
in across the street right before
Thanksgiving and ends up having her
turkey dinner with one of their other
neighbors who eventually passes away now
at that point with all due respect to
the deceased it's game on for John and
Max the movie also includes a couple
Thanksgiving settings and conversations
at the homes of John and Max with some
of the supporting casts like Kevin
Pollock and Daryl Hannah along with the
actual tea giving moments Grumpy Old Men
also captures that General winter in the
midwest feeling that usually kicks in by
late November now ironically though
filming was set to begin in January of
1993 in Minnesota but had to wait until
February due to a lack of snowfall
oh no
looks a rubber room
oh
I fixed your fishing pole there's about
a damn fishing pole he's in shove that
pole you think a lousy old pole is gonna
replace her
and in the true Spirit of the
Thanksgiving holiday one of the central
themes of this movie is the importance
of family and friends that includes both
in front of and behind the camera given
that this was the sixth out of 10 film
that would pair up friends lemon and
mouth out to keep the Good Vibes going
the screenplay was written by Mark
Steven Johnson a film student at Winona
State University at the time and in his
first writing credit he went on to write
Grumpier Old Men plus films like Jack
Frost Daredevil and Ghost Rider I mean
what's not to love about a behind the
scenes success story for someone who was
no doubt thankful for the opportunity
Miracle on 34th Street imagine
making a child it's like something it
doesn't want just because he bought too
many of the wrong toys
that's what I've been fighting against
for years the way they commercialize
Christmas yeah there's a lot of badisms
floating around as well but one of the
wastest commercialism make a buck makeup
even in Brooklyn it's the same don't
care what Christmas stands but just make
a buck make up now next on this list of
the best Thanksgiving movies is 1947's
Miracle on 34th Street now this film
which takes place in New York City
between Thanksgiving and Christmas was
written and directed by George Seaton
and based on a story by Valentine Davies
in it Edmund Gwen plays an old man who
goes by the name Kris Kringle who fills
in for an intoxicated Santa in the
annual Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade he
soon becomes a regular Santa for the
Chain's main store but once he starts
claiming that he's in fact the real
Santa Claus it leads to a court case to
determine if what he's saying is real
thank you
your honor every one of these letters is
addressed to Santa Claus the post office
has delivered them therefore the post
office Department a branch of the
federal government recognizes this man
Kris Kringle to be the one and only
Santa Claus now one of the great things
about this movie especially in a
Thanksgiving sense is that filming took
place during the actual Macy's Parade in
1946 one of the most long-standing
Thanksgiving traditions in the United
States it was a bitterly cold day and
nine cameras were used simultaneously to
capture everything that they needed with
one take not only that Edmund Gwen
played Santa in the actual parade and
fulfilled most of the duties of any
parade Santa including addressing the
crowd from the Macy's Marquee at the end
now to go along with those obvious
connections to the Thanksgiving holiday
and just a feel-good family vibe that
comes from the story The Legacy and
tradition of this film continues to hold
up as well Miracle on 34th Street was
actually up for four Oscars including
best picture and it took home three one
for Edmund Gwen's supporting performance
and two for the writing it actually
became one of the first full-length
black and white films to be colorized in
1985 and a fresh remake make with John
Hughes co-writing and producing came out
in 1994 with Richard Attenborough
playing Kris Kringle but it's hard to
match the certified fresh original with
the critics consensus that calls it
quote irrefutable proof that gentle
sentimentalism can be the chief
ingredient in a wonderful film
Scent of a Woman I've been around you
know
there was a time I could see
and I have seen
boys like these younger than these their
arms torn out their legs ripped off
but there is nothing like a sight of an
amputated Spirit snooping around for a
spot on this list is 1992's Scent of a
Woman directed by Martin breast of
Beverly Hills Cop theme at the time this
is a remake of a 1974 Italian film both
of which were adapted from a 1969 novel
by Giovanni Arpino now the movie
revolves around Chris O'Donnell's
Charlie a student who is looking to get
home for Christmas so he agrees to look
after a retired army lieutenant colonel
over Thanksgiving played by Al Pacino
who is now blind and tough to get along
with the film features a Thanksgiving
dinner scene where Pacino's character
Frank decides to provoke his brother and
others at the table leading to a heated
confrontation that sounds about right
[Music]
I'll just let go please
now sometimes to be truly thankful for
what you have it's nice to look back at
what could have been and in this case
young stars like Brendan Fraser Stephen
Dorff and of course Matt Damon and Ben
Affleck were among those who auditioned
for Charlie before O'Donnell was cast
and Jack Nicholson was actually offered
the role of Lieutenant Colonel Frank but
turned it down before Pacino was
eventually cast and Al made the most of
it now to help understand what it's like
to be blind Pacino actually met with
people who had lost their sight due to
trauma and was schooled by local New
York organizations and different
techniques a blind person might use to
do things like seat themselves poor
liquid and light a cigar so clearly it's
pretty easy to be thankful for the cast
that was Pacino finally won his first
Oscar for acting after seven previous
nominations and he won the Golden Globe
for best actor to go with the film's
wins for best screenplay and best drama
pour in a box office gross of just over
134 million and it is all gravy baby
Pieces of April this was long ago
[Music]
um
before we
stole almost their land
killed most of them and
move the rest of reservations
before they lost their language and
their customs
okay
um
forget what I just said
coming together for the next spot on
this list is 2003's Pieces of April this
film follows April a rebellious and
quirky girl played by Katie Holmes who
lives with her boyfriend in a low rent
NYC apartment miles from her family now
despite that she ends up inviting the
whole crew over for Thanksgiving dinner
after learning that her mom played by
Patricia Clarkson has a fatal form of
cancer to take the Thanksgiving themes
even further while April's family
struggles with the complicated drive
into the city she's forced to turn to a
neighbor played by Sean Hayes for help
after running into kitchen trouble
thankfully for fans of Patricia Clarkson
this was a great vehicle for her talents
and ended up being a big success for her
career she was actually nominated for a
Screen Actors Guild Golden Globe
independent spirit and Academy Award for
best supporting actress for her
performance and she brought home
hardware from the national board of
review National Society of film critics
the Sundance Film Festival and the
satellite Awards among others dang girl
would you knock where is she I don't
know who
your mother
honey
Mom Mother mommy Joy
okay everybody let's move it piece of
April was written and directed by Peter
Hedges marking his directorial debut
after writing films like What's Eating
Gilbert Grape and about a boy he is the
father of Academy Award nominated actor
Lucas Hedges and I'm telling you that
because well thanksgiving's all about
family isn't it well it's not all about
family it's mainly about food but you
get the idea now this movie also found a
few reasons to be thankful at the box
office as well bringing in three million
dollars against a 300 and thousand
dollar budget the certified fresh flick
has found a good place for critics as
well like Sheila Norman Culp from the
Associated Press who said quote
Thanksgiving just wouldn't be
Thanksgiving without a dysfunctional
family reunion but writer director Peter
Hedges comes up with an original take on
the holiday disaster theme The Blind
Side do you have any place to stay
tonight
don't you dare lie to me
I've seen that look many times she's
about to get her away looking to grab
the next spot on this list is 2009's The
Blind Side this film was written and
directed by John Lee Hancock and based
on the 2006 non-fiction book of the same
name by Michael Lewis in it Quentin
Aaron plays a homeless team named
Michael Orr who has drifted in and out
of the education system for years he's
taken in by Leanne and Sean Tui played
by Sandra Bullock and Tim McGraw and
eventually develops into a great student
and a professional caliber football
Talent as well now the Blind Side came
out around Thanksgiving time in 2009 and
is stuffed full of all the good family
feelings that you can handle one of the
more pivotal scenes is when Michael eats
a Thanksgiving meal with the two e's and
finally starts to feel like he's part of
the family now the scene is emotional
and it makes you feel good and it leads
to his character opening up more in
general you have no idea what this boy's
been through and if this is going to
become some running diatribe I can find
an overpriced salad a lot closer to home
Leanne I'm so sorry we didn't intend to
we didn't really I think what you're
doing is so great to open up your home
to him
I know you're changing that boy's life
no
and in a
CE hi Julia Roberts was offered the lead
but turned it down before Sandra Bullock
was eventually cast she took a pay cut
with a percentage of the profits instead
and it's a good thing she did not only
because the film grows 309 million
dollars against a 29 million dollar
budget but because she picked up a whole
trophy case worth of prizes for this one
we're talking Oscar sag and Golden Globe
awards to go along with the Blind Side
also winning best picture at the Academy
Awards but you gotta love a happy ending
which is that Michael Orr went on to
earn a Super Bowl ring with the
Baltimore Ravens in Super Bowl 47
because after all the most important
tradition on Thanksgiving isn't family
or food it's NFL football just saying A
Charlie Brown Thanksgiving why should I
give thanks on Thanksgiving what if I
got to be thankful for all it does is
make more work for us at school
do you know what what we have to do now
[Music]
we have to write an essay on Stanley
miles and finally because we don't want
any problems here this list would not be
complete without the 1973 TV special A
Charlie Brown Thanksgiving now this
marked the 10th Prime Time animated
special based on the popular comic strip
peanuts by Charles M scholz and the
third holiday special after the
Christmas one in 65 and the Halloween
one in 66. now in this special
Peppermint Patty invites herself and her
friends over to Charlie Brown's for
Thanksgiving and he has to try and throw
something together with the help of
Linus Snoopy and Woodstock yeah good
luck with that now their holiday
celebration includes Linus leading the
group in a prayer that also tells the
story of the first Thanksgiving in 1621
and later Peppermint Patty's shock and
outrage over the unconventional meal now
wait a minute sir did he invite you here
to dinner or did you invite yourself and
us too
gee I never thought of it like that do
you think I heard old Chuck's feelings I
bet I hurt his feelings huh golly why
can't I act right outside of a baseball
game
Marcy maybe you can go to old Chuck and
patch things up for me
maybe you can tell him how I really feel
tell him that I didn't mean it the way
it sounded
Marcy you can do it you go see him and
tell him that I really like him and that
the dinner is okay with me the special
first aired on CBS on November 20th 1973
and went on to win an Emmy the following
year on its way to becoming a popular
annual tradition for families around
Thanksgiving it is aired on TV nearly
every year since 1973 with a switch to
ABC along the way and later on PBS is
part of a deal with the current owner of
all things peanuts Apple TV plus and
while there was another Thanksgiving
theme special in 1988 this is America
Charlie Brown which tells the story of
the pilgrims it's this special that has
endured now a big reason for that is the
highly recognizable musical scorer by
the Vince Guaraldi trio now there was no
official soundtrack but the songs have
been scattered throughout the Universe
on different compilation albums and they
are still as recognizable as ever and
will most definitely transport you to a
very specific time and place where
turkey was most likely involved well my
friends we did it we got through our
list of the best Thanksgiving movies and
we didn't even stop for a snack break
like I don't know a turkey sandwich much
or something guys I'm starving I mean
I'm just dying to know what are your
favorite Thanksgiving movies maybe start
by checking out some of the ones on this
list to get your juices flowing like a
delicious juicy turkey with stuffing and
mashed potatoes and gravy and maybe more
stuffing all right I gotta go thanks for
tuning in to Rotten Tomatoes Essentials
I'm your hungry host Naz Perez and I'll
see you next time Happy Thanksgiving
[Music]
thank you